cette pomme de terre vaut de l'or rare
exigeante on la récolte à la main la
bonnotte variété exclusivement produites
sur l'île de noirmoutier a failli
disparaître seuls les anciens la
cultivait encore comme un trésor
mon grand père avait avec son petit
ballon au fond au bout de planche chez
lui où il avait sa petite bonne note
donc elle était pas du tout
commercialisé il donnait sa la famille
aux amis s'étaient c'était le nec le
plus ultra la pomme de terre c'était
s'étaient donnés pas à n'importe qui
c'était le cadeau
depuis cinq ans cette pomme de terre en
lavant 20 francs le kilo la production a
été relancée mais à petite échelle
seulement 50 tonnes sont commercialisés
une rareté qui augmente la demande et à
coopérative de noirmoutier l'ambiance
est fiable c'est tous les ans comme ça
c'est un petit peu
la pomme de terre nouvelle
le beaujolais nouveau le muguet à senna
produits prime 1 3 jours et 2 jours de
récolte un jour de vente et tout et tout
est vendu est effectivement aux normands
mais franchement c'est une pomme de
terre trop difficile à faire pour
pouvoir être mis sur le marché plus
longtemps de l'avis des gastronomes la
bonnotte un goût unique de noisettes
pour l'apprécier il s'agit de la
cuisiner simplement et sans l'éplucher
mais ça l'a fait le beurre à l'ail elle
concerne arrivée à bruxelles
mais quoi les boudins passer sous l'eau
qui vous l'a fait sauter au beurre vert
la belote est une aubaine pour les
producteurs de lui car ici la pomme de
terre primeur est une institution on en
récolte plus de dix mille tonnes et la
bonnotte fait connaître le savoir-faire
de noirmoutier